previously on TV since let's have a look
Rita we can appraise the appraisal wow
you and I play a game off you go first
[Music]
since we're nitpicking this incredible
show anyway why the does Morty have a
coat hung up on the wall here does he
really have no closet there is this a
trophy from a serial killing Rick turns
on a light but the obvious light on the
ceiling does not light up coming from
some magical source in a room with only
one switch exact conversation I have
with my college girlfriend during
jean-claude Van Damme night at our local
BDSM film dungeon somehow makes it into
the show look if you want to know what
we're up against here the mother moon is
drawn with such care here that they
included the phasing shadow the level of
thought that went into this show is
astounding well played Joe well played I
found in the garage did you though the
trash can and the flashlight sure but
I'm pretty sure you had to get this
high-density bubble glass and these
giant screws custom-made where did you
find the giant cylinder base for this
spaceship in the garage it also looks
like most of the stuff that you attach
to this thing wouldn't aid in flying but
hinder it why would Rick even install
seatbelts in the first place does he
strike you as the kind of person while
throwing together a junk crafted
space-time ship in his garage stops for
a second and thinks but first safety how
are these two so close when Rick clearly
landed several feet away when he fell
out of the ship opening title spoilers
also I know Rick and Morty where's its
references on its sleeve but this
opening theme song couldn't be more
Doctor Who if Tom Baker and David
Tennant were in a threesome with the
ghost of William Hartnell while Russell
T Davies watched also also intro
promises an episode where Morty is a
robot and doesn't come through ever
there are two or three other things in
this the intro promises and doesn't
deliver and I'm calling my local Adult
Swim about it what is this pink liquid
are the Smiths drinking pepto for
breakfast I mean with this family I
guess that might make sense I mean if he
told me Jerry ends up mixing it with
whiskey and has a fondness for barbed
wire I wouldn't say you were wrong
two plus two she's hilarious that Rick
said that school was exactly this and it
happens as soon as Morty gets to school
but this isn't the first day is it what
did they get taught in the time leading
up to this you know what I named these
my little Morty's
you know what I want you to do with him
rename them honestly this kind of joke
deserves us in removal but he's dreaming
about this
so he's dreaming about Jessica showing
him her boobs having her called them her
little Morty's and then negging her for
it's like he mastered Neil straws as the
game but is only good at it when he's
dreaming we got we gotta get the hell
out of here and go take care of business
what's with dirty sanchez always having
goop in his mouth and the constant
belching with this level of acid reflux
I'm guessing Rick's ulcers are on the
verge of ending his life I'm just saying
if we don't find out in a future episode
that the belching and the mouth splooge
is actually caused by an
interdimensional species that lives in
his gut bacteria I'll lose a lot of
respect for the show now if you just
stick with me morning I'm gonna be
predator pauses predator in prioritizing
panicking protagonist punchline past
partaking of perfectly palatable people
first act ends on a cliffhanger for a
commercial break only to return with
Rick and Morty no longer in danger in
the monster gone and nobody mentioning
it again man sure that could be some
sort of comedic point about the
worthlessness of commercial cliffhangers
but you think a show like this might
acknowledge it a little bit just take
these shoes Morty I convenience them out
of my lab code of conveniences these
things really bring it all together you
have to turn them on Morty sure Rick
looks like a total [ __ ] for not
telling Morty about turning the shoes on
before he fell into the ravine but
Morty's kind of an [ __ ] for being
this trusting of Rick and deciding to
dive in headfirst without even a
question
Morty survives this is he immortal yeah
it's a cartoon and I get it but in what
alternate universe could a LED broken in
at least three places continue to stay
elevated like this I went into a future
dimension with such advanced medicine
that they had broken leg serum at every
corner drugstore nice echoing of the
Back to the Future line there but what
kind of place is it that people are
breaking their legs so much the
broken-leg Serum is a viably
mass-produced medicine Rick separates
the sea but there is somehow a full seed
in each half now knowing this show that
could completely be intentional and is
some sort of paradoxical joke that will
be retcon into a storyline in season 42
but the pickings here be slim so for now
I'm gonna need you to take these seeds
into the bathroom and I'm gonna need you
to put them way up inside your butthole
Morty Morty full of grace no fall right
out of mine I've done this too many
times party sure Rick is a quasi evil
drunken [ __ ] and an unreliable
character overall but didn't he tell
Morty what do you think I could just do
it all by myself and now he's saying
he's done this law
sometimes maybe Rick just wanted to
spend time with Morty I'll grant that
but I'm taking my sin and going home
come on Morty please more you have to do
it more man Rick says Morty at least a
hundred times in this first episode I'm
sure it's on purpose for some sort of
comedic effect but damn the effect wears
off quick why didn't you notify us if
you're not been getting the messages
I've been leaving with Morty's
grandfather sure this principal is dumb
but if he's been calling Morty's
grandfather and leaving messages that
apparently have been going unheeded for
two months wouldn't you try and call the
parents at work isn't that how you got
in contact with them this time wait is
there just an unguarded portal just
lying around at this Airport no
employees no other people waiting in
line honey it's our son with Albert I'm
do Sh
I mean Nikola Tesla was right there but
sure whatever sure this background joke
is hilarious because it's a towing
company that has a mascot that's a tow
with eyes named toe whose catchphrase is
I toe which could both be interpreted as
I am doing towing as well as hello my
name is tow but the important thing to
note here is that toes don't bend like
that I didn't know hanging out with you
is making me smarter temporary
superintelligence is just a side effect
of the mega C's dissolving in your
rectal cavity oh really then why did
Morty only show super intelligence when
you asked him questions to fool his mom
and dad feels rather convenient but how
can I hate the show since don't matter
and I need those seats real bad not in
this episode you didn't meaning those
seeds are about the MacGuffin iasts
thing to ever Mack all over my guns
agent hurly I want you to give this come
I got cavity search I'm talking
roto-rooter yeah very nosy fellow kitty
cat huh you know what happens to nosy
fellas I went into a future dimension
with such advanced medicine that they
had broken leg serum at every corner
drugstore every corner drugstore but in
1955 it's a little hard to come by he's
got some kind of disability or something
is that what you want us to say I do
plausible I know but I like to imagine
that he had sex the night before and now
a little bit of residue is blocking his
urethra oh geez dead you know that's a
lot to drop on a kid all at once